ein science fiction wird realität
forschenden ist es gelungen den
entscheidenden baustein das gehen zu
finden um das gehirn von affen wachsen
zu lassen wie beim menschen und nicht
nur das sie haben es angewendet und die
affen gehirne weisen nach der
genmanipulation noch eine rein
menschliche eigenschaft auf klicks um
science im future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
dann verpasst er nichts
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen clixoom gibt es
jetzt auch als podcast auf die ohren
klick auf die links zu spotify und apple
podcast in der video beschreibung und
hier und ami
möglicherweise hat nur eine kleine
mutation im erbgut bewirkt dass sich das
leben auf der erde komplett veränderte
sprache kultur schrift religion
wissenschaft und architektur
das sind nur einige der errungenschaften
die wir anderen primaten voraus haben
außerdem haben wir auch visionen
fantasie das alles ist letztendlich und
vereinfacht gesagt auf unser vergrößert
das gehirn zurückzuführen
doch wie ist dieses entstanden was
sorgte dafür dass es plötzlich begann zu
wachsen
der vergrößerte neokortex der mit
abstand größte teil des gehirns geht
jedenfalls als ein markenzeichen der
entstehung des menschen das zeigt der
vergleich des hirnvolumens bei einem
schimpansen handelt es sich um rund
einen halben liter ein erwachsener
mensch dagegen verfügt über knapp 1,5
liter volumen
es hat sich verdreifacht aber wodurch
forschungsteams weltweit gingen bislang
davon aus dass diese entwicklung linear
verlief demnach müsste das kann also im
laufe der zeit immer ein stückchen
größer geworden seien
die entwicklung des menschen musste
dieser theorie zufolge also quasi
zwangsläufig geschehen sein doch ein
forschungsteam vom max-planck-institut
für molekulare zellbiologie und genetik
in dresden hat jetzt offenbart dass
diese annahme ein trugschluss sein
könnte demnach könnte ist eine einfache
punkt mutation im erbgut gewesen sein
die zu einem rasanten wachstum des
gehirns geführt hat wenn dies
tatsächlich so stimmt wäre unsere
entstehung ein banaler zufall in diesem
video geht es um die forschung der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus dresden
und wie sie zu ihrer gewagten these
gekommen sind konkret geht es um das
gehen mit der bezeichnung allrad fb und
über genau dieses gen verfügen nur wir
menschen fachleute sind überzeugt davon
dass ergab fb dafür sorgt dass mehr hirn
stammzellen gebildet werden und genau
das führt letztendlich dann zu einem
größeren gehirn und hier sind wir
menschen ganz weit vorne unser gehirn
ist größer als das aller primaten und
etwa drei mal so groß wie das eines
schimpansen unser nächster verwandter in
der fachsprache ist vom neokortex die
rede gemeint ist hiermit der evolutionär
jüngsten teil der großhirnrinde und eben
der größte er musste sich falten um
überhaupt in den begrenzten raum der
schädel höhle zu passen und ermöglicht
uns menschen höhere kognitive
fähigkeiten wie die sprache oder das
denken doch wie konnte der menschliche
neokortex so groß werden wie ist es
damals dazu gekommen dass er überhaupt
gewachsen ist ist dieser gewaltige
unterschied etwa auf das gehen ergab fb
zurückzuführen dass nur im menschlichen
gehirn aktiv ist handelt es sich hierbei
also um den evolutionären schlüssel für
ein vergrößertes gehirn genau dieser
zentralen frage gingen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus leipzig nach bereits vor fünf jahren
2015 hatten die fachleute die ersten
hinweise darauf gefunden im tierversuch
mit mäusen hatten sie festgestellt dass
sich das gehirn der tiere verändert wenn
es unter einfluss des human spezifischen
gens ergab 11 besteht dann nämlich
produzierten die mäuse in ihrem
embryonalen neokortex vielmehr neuronale
vorläuferzellen zudem zeigten die
tierversuche dass der neokortex unter
diesen umständen sogar gefaltet ist und
das obwohl er bei den mäusen
normalerweise glatt ist verantwortlich
dafür ist wohl eine der insgesamt zwei
arten von neuronalen vorläuferzellen im
neokortex von säugetieren die
sogenannten basalen radialen die ja
zählen
diese sehen forschungsteams weltweit als
hauptursache für das wachstum des
neokortex während der embryonalen
entwicklung der mäuse aber nur über
wenige dieser bestimmten zellen verfügen
weiteten die dresdner
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ihre versuche in der vergangenheit
zunächst auf frettchen aus der
wissenschaftler georg albiez war an dem
suchen beteiligt und fasst die
ergebnisse aus der vergangenheit
folgendermaßen zusammen bei frettchen
hatakka bfb die anzahl der basalen
radialen gliazellen deutlich erhöht es
verlängerte auch das zeitfenster in dem
die basalen radialen gliazellen neurone
produzierten infolgedessen enthielten
diese frettchen hirne mehr neuronen und
hatten somit einen größeren neokortex
ein starker hinweis also darauf dass das
gen ergab 11 b auch bei der entwicklung
des menschlichen gehirns eine
entscheidende rolle gespielt haben
könnte mittlerweile wissen die fachleute
mehr
sie gehen davon aus dass dieses gen vor
rund fünf millionen jahren entstanden
sein muss hier haben sich wohl zwei
revolutionslieder voneinander getrennt
die eine führte zum neandertaler dem
modernen menschen und dem denisova
menschen und die andere führte zum
schimpansen nach ansicht des
forschungsteams entstand das menschen
spezifische gfb wohl konkret durch die
teilweise verdoppelung des
weitverbreiteten gsa gab elf in der
fachsprache ist von einer partiellen
gehen verdopplung die rede
wodurch die zellen die möglichkeit
bekommen neue funktionen auszuführen
quasi so wie man auf dem smartphone oder
dem laptop speicherplatz frei macht um
neue kapazitäten zu schaffen klar dabei
ist dass dadurch nicht automatisch auch
neue inhalte entstehen heißt also die
gen verdoppelung an sich verändert
funktional gesehen erst mal gar nichts
vereinfacht gesagt bilden genia die
einheiten der vererbung konkret handelt
es sich um dna abschnitte auf den
chromosomen die wichtige informationen
enthalten damit bestimmte proteine
hergestellt werden können das protein
das von dem gfb abgeleitet wird enthält
eine sequenz von 47 aminosäuren die für
den menschen spezifisch sind erst diese
sequenz ermöglicht die vermehrung von
hirn stammzellen im aargau protein kommt
sie nicht vor
die ursache dafür ist äußerst
überraschend der unterschied ist
tatsächlich ein einziger von drei
millionen chemischen bausteinen im
erbgut der ausgetauscht wurde hier
ersetzte die base guanin abgekürzt mit
dem buchstaben g die base cytosin
abgekürzt mit dem buchstaben c und genau
diese winzige mutation im erbgut sorgte
möglicherweise erst dafür dass sich das
leben auf der erde grundlegend
veränderte und die entwicklung vom affen
zum
von anfang an dabei sind mutationen an
sich nicht selten doch diese eine war
offensichtlich folgenschweren dazu der
führende wissenschaftler aus dresden
wieland huttner
tatsächlich führte lediglich der
punktuelle austausch eines einzigen
genetischen buchstaben es nämlich der
austausch von c zu gfb gehen zum verlust
von 55 nukleotiden bei der bildung der
entsprechenden boten rna das hatte eine
verschiebung im leser raster zu folgen
die wiederum zu der menschen
spezifischen funktionell essentiellen
sequenz von 47 aminosäuren im protein
führt punktmutation treten relativ
häufig auch doch im fall von apb scheint
der vorteil so gravierend gewesen zu
sein dass diese genetische variante die
menschliche evolution unmittelbar
beeinflusst hat heißt also im klartext
diese punktmutation ist entscheidend und
ausschlaggebend sie ändert alles sie
verleiht dem gfb die fähigkeit
stammzellen zu vermehren und das gehirn
zu vergrößern es kommt zu einer extremen
zellteilung vergleichbar wie sie bei
tumoren auftritt doch die zellteilung
die durch das gen zustande kommt
verläuft kontrolliert und stoppt dann
irgendwann auch wieder
wichtig hierbei das gehen selbst ist
nach ansicht der fachleute wohl bereits
vor fünf millionen jahren entstanden die
punktmutation dagegen erst deutlich
später nämlich in einem geschätzen
zeitraum von vor 125 millionen bis rund
500.000 jahren doch wie wirkt dieses gfb
das eigentlich nur beim menschen
vorkommt bei nichtmenschlichen primaten
um das zu erforschen wann transgene
tiere notwendig tiere also die durch
gentechnische verfahren verändert worden
das forschungsteam aus dresden setzte
hierbei auf eine kooperation mit der
keio universität aus japan an dem
zentralen institut für versuchstiere
werden technologien er arbeitet mit den
transgenen nicht menschlichen primaten
erzeugt werden können auf diese art und
weise entstanden weiß püschel affen die
das gen akp in sich tragen und jetzt
wird es extrem spannend ja und auch
unangenehm stichwort tierversuche dazu
entnahmen die japanischen forschern die
gehirne von weißbüscheläffchen föten und
zwar 50 tage vor dem normalen
geburtsdatum die unterschiede zu den
gilt
technisch nicht modifizierten tieren
waren schnell auszumachen dazu der
wissenschaftler michael heyde
wir stellten in der tat fest dass der
neokortex des gehirns der weiß püschel
affen vergrößert und die hirn oberfläche
gefaltet war auch die sogenannte
courtial platte war dicker als normal
darüber hinaus fanden wir eine höhere
anzahl bestimmter vorläuferzellen der
basalen radialen gliazellen in der
äußeren sub-band regulären zone sowie
eine höhere anzahl von neuronen in den
oberen schichten der großhirnrinde
diese drehten charakteristischer weise
in der primaten evolution vermehrt auf
die bilder im vergleich zeigen es ganz
deutlich dass normale gehirn eines weiß
püschel affen fotos ist im vergleich zu
den gleich alten gehirn das unter dem
einfluss des menschlichen gfb gehen
steht deutlich kleiner
die analyse der affen gehirne offenbarte
also eine echte premiere
die ersten funktionellen beweise dafür
dass das gen afb zu einem vergrößerten
neokortex bei primaten führen kann
das legen auch die gegen versuchen wenn
das gen ausgeschaltet wird nimmt das
nicht an stammzellen zu bislang wurden
neben ag insgesamt 14 gene identifiziert
die alleine im menschlichen gehirn aktiv
sind doch nur dass gaga fb gehen hat
derart entscheidende auswirkungen auf
das höhere wachstum diese ergebnisse
sprechen nach ansicht des
forschungsteams eindeutig dafür dass das
gen afb im laufe der evolution
tatsächlich dafür gesorgt haben könnten
dass sich der menschliche neokortex
vergrössern klar ist jedoch auch dass
nicht allein die größe entscheidend für
intelligenz ist dazu der hirnforscher
wieland huttner
da sind sicherlich noch andere
veränderung genom die sich in der
vernetzung von nervenzellen auswirken
aber die vergrößerung des menschlichen
gehirns ist eine wichtige voraussetzung
für unsere besonderen kognitiven
fähigkeiten das weiß man weil auch
menschen geboren werden die lediglich
über die hirngröße eines schimpansen
verfügen diese sind nach ihrem denken
deutlich eingeschränkt doch versuche
zeigen dass diese personen dennoch
klüger als schimpansen sind heißt also
die größe des gehirns ist eine wichtige
basis für die kognitiven fähigkeiten der
menschen
doch zudem gibt es wohl noch weitere
faktoren die uns intellektuell zu
menschen machen die wissenschaft ist
dabei die details zu ergründen spannend
die fahrer dabei ob unser gehirn in der
zukunft möglicherweise noch einmal einen
solchen sprung in seiner entwicklung
durchmachen könnte der hirnforscher
wieland huttner hält das für
unwahrscheinlich in einem interview sagt
er es ist kaum vorstellbar dass sich
eine einzige mutation im gen pool von
sechs milliarden menschen durch selbst
viel größer eine population desto
unwahrscheinlicher ist dass menschen mit
besonderen kognitiven gaben entstehen
natürlich andauern aber einen sprung für
die intellektuellen fähigkeiten der
gesamten menschheit sehe ich aktuell
eher nicht die aktuellen
forschungsergebnisse aus dresden lösen
also endlich das große rätsel wie wir
menschen zu unserem großen gehirn kommen
konnten nun wissen wir also endlich wann
und warum in der evolution unser hirn
größer wurde aber nicht nur dass die
neuen erkenntnisse könnten
möglicherweise auch in der medizin
anwendung finden die fachleute wollen
neue behandlungsansätze für krankheiten
finden bei den hirnzellen absterben das
ist beispielsweise bei alzheimer und
parkinson der fall es bleibt also
spannend wieviel gigabyte passen ins
gehirn eine ziemlich spannende frage die
jakob von breaking lab und ich in diesem
video beantworten also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar diesen
kanal besand bleibt dran